The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
Introductions, Audrey Schulman.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Hey.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: HEET, Home
Energy Efficiency Team.
I'm Nathan Phillips.
I teach at Boston University.
And the previous
speakers, I think,
really talk to how the
environmental problems
that we have are either
invisible or very hard
to grasp.
So being able to see these
things with evidence,
photographs or having
simple and precise metrics
to understand the magnitude
of our climate impacts
is important.
So this is very much
in line with this.
And so some of you
here have been with us
from the start, when we met
here a couple of weeks ago.
Some of you came in midstream.
So we laid out this problem
about the methane gas leaks
from the natural gas
pipeline infrastructure
under Boston, Cambridge,
Somerville, Eastern United
States.
Then we talked about solutions.
We had a hackathon about a week
and a half ago or a week ago.
And then, yesterday,
Audrey and I,
and some of the people in
this room, hopped in a van,
and we started sniffing
these gas leaks
and mapping them
on Google Earth.
And so we just wanted
to share with you--
how many people were
actually in the van with us?
So a good chunk of us here.
So this was us yesterday.
And this is a combined map
here of both of the trips
that we took.
So the first van load, we
had a full van of 12 people,
and we drove from here
to Somerville and back.
And then we pretty
much did the same thing
with a little slight
variation in the second trip.
So let's see-- so that's
where we are right now,
is that correct, Audrey?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah,
and an important thing
to know is that there's
a baseline about two
parts per million in this,
so that the wall, everywhere,
is just a baseline of
methane that exists.
That used to be lower--
NATHAN PHILLIPS: No,
let's share this, please.
But actually please--
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: So it's Mercer
Street, that's the methane leak?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah,
so there's a big league
somewhere here, right in front
of the most iconic part of MIT.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Oh
sorry, you want me to?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Oh, I'll do it.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: But the wall
here that you see of everywhere
where we drove?
That's sort of just the
parts per million of methane
that's just background noise.
And the big spikes are
where there were leaks.
So and what's interesting is,
we did a US survey of Cambridge
and Somerville two years ago,
and there was a leak here.
So there still is.
It's nice to know.
What do you want to say?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Well, how
about we go to the area,
where it was it, Prince
Street in Somerville?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Pearl Street.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Pearl Street.
Let's take a look at.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So here's
us going by Kendall.
And then back--
I'm having a prankster.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Thanks
for driving, Audrey.
I'm not good at Mac.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: OK, yeah no.
Mac is my language.
So that's Pearl Street
there, the big mountains.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Now.
These are all
National Grid, right?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah so the
difference between Eversource
and National Grid is this
train track right here.
So this is Eversource down here,
this is National Grid up there.
And we don't know
what's going on,
whether there's a
difference in its operating
pressure of the pipes,
or age of the pipes,
material of the pipes, or
difference in how the two
companies deal with leaks.
But you know, two years
ago, when we did the survey,
there were--
you know, this area of National
Grid's was the Swiss Alps
of Somerville.
And it seems to
still be that way.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: So just
a couple of observations.
And please, you were there,
so offer your own observations
or questions about
this because this
is a very rich data set there.
It raises lots of
questions to me.
So you can see here, there's
actually a couple traces,
right?
Here there's two traces.
We drove it two
times in two trips.
You see that there some
variation each time.
And we talked about
the vagaries of wind,
and you know, if the
wind's blowing harder
in one direction
one time, you'll
get something
slightly different.
So is this a leak?
Is it the same thing as this?
What do we actually--
how do we take
continuous data like this
and objectify it in terms
of, well, there is a leak.
It's difficult.
It's tricky to do.
And you know there
are pipeline leaks.
There are holes in pipes.
And then there
are methane leaks.
And they come out of the ground.
So even the terminology we use
is not quite fully worked out.
There's a lot here.
Some of the things that--
so in terms of, at one
level, at a very broad level,
Pearl Street is a mess.
It's leaking methane
all along that street.
When we get to
policy, state policy
makers and the utilities,
and the regulators
want to know, well, how
many leaks are there?
Because that determines,
like, how many
crews that are going to
go out, and how they're
going to schedule, and
how they're going to get
reimbursed, or repaid for
a fixed number of things
that they do.
So this is a complicated
kind of policy science
type of framework.
Do you have any
other observations?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah,
I want to point out
one thing in terms of policy.
This area right
here is where they'd
taken out the cast iron
main that is quite old
and put in plastic.
And we could see--
I think that that's right.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Franklin,
is that Franklin?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah
I'm assuming that is.
We can go in closer.
But there was one
part where we saw
that they've taken
out the old gas main
and put in a new, better one.
And I'm betting it's that area.
AUDIENCE: So, were
you surprised by this?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Not any more.
So when we published our first
publication in late 2012,
early 2013, it basically
made it a problem
that was well known to the
utilities known to, at least,
I don't want to say everyone,
but people who saw the paper,
and members of the public that
read some of the press that
came out about it.
So that was unexpected
to the utilities.
And it kind of
knocked them back.
It's like, oh, we have
data that's coming out.
So they didn't control the data.
And so just by virtue of
having data out there,
it has basically,
kind of say, balanced
the power a little bit, or a
lot, to get change to happen
and policy to be made.
Is this Franklin?
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
Yeah, I don't know.
I couldn't see.
I tried to figure it out.
Anybody know
Somerville really well?
What's the street
parallel to Roland?
AUDIENCE: Can you assign these
leaks to a specific pipe?
What's the spatial resolution
of assigning a spike to the--?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah,
so when we go by here,
any one of these kind of
discrete spikes, the window
in which leaks may be
coming out is probably
on the border of a
few tens of meters.
And that's dictated both
by the spatial source.
It may-- even one pipeline
leak, like I said,
could be coming up
in various locations,
and then the wind may
be blowing it around.
So that's what this
is allowing us to do.
But then streets sometimes have
multiple pipelines running down
the same street.
Sometimes they only have one
main running down the street.
So you have to go in a
little more carefully
and use, basically,
probes that check
what's coming out of the
ground to actually pinpoint
the actual pipe and
where it's leaking.
So this doesn't do this.
This basically just says,
Pearl Street is a mess,
and it's got a lot
of leak problems.
And it requires a walking survey
to go back and to be more--
AUDIENCE: Have you done some
very basic signal processing
on it?
So run a low pass
filter just to get rid
of the small frequencies?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: No, and I think
that's the type of analysis
that would be
fabulous to do here.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Know
anybody who can help?
AUDIENCE: I can take it farther.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] You
can detect the pattern that
reflects the leak--
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
So here's one thing
that I think we all
Audrey and I have
been trying to make progress on
is, how do you take this data
and use it to help us start
to quantify how much is coming
out?
And that's also a very difficult
thing because, first of all,
you're looking at this, and it
implies something quantitative,
but you don't see any
numbers here, right?
So probably you're wondering,
well, how big are these spikes?
And actually, you know,
this data just came out,
so I haven't been
able to process,
but we know that this is
sitting right around 2.0,
maybe 1.95, I forget
what our baseline is.
It's in the KML file.
We could open that up.
It's just a text file.
It tells you what we
set the baseline at--
that baseline can shift
from day to day, by the way.
What is this value?
I'll have to find it out.
It would be great to have--
we were talking about something
that some students could
do is come up with a processor
that just basically plops
numbers on here.
So we could see that.
What was the concentration?
If we go, you know, just
for setting the scale,
I remember, and the
four of us in the van
for the second round, we
went to Sullivan Square.
And I think, what was the
top read we got there?
We were reading it off.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: It
was like 90, wasn't it?
Wasn't it something
really ridiculous?
I've never seen
that number before.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: I recall
up around 67 or 70 parts
per million in the air.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So it's
that spike right there, see?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: So there's
something really interesting
about this.
So we can put numbers on that.
We have done that,
and it's just,
we haven't had a
chance to do it.
But actually this is really
a very interesting issue
of data display.
I'd be interested-- who's
that data person that,
the display of data--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah, I'd
be interested to hear someone
like that's take because
there was a utility
person from National Grid
that basically called us out
on this.
And the point this
person made was,
it's like, you're scaring
people by doing this.
You're taking-- it's an
apples and oranges thing.
You're putting some data.
And all of the houses, and all
of us, are, like, down here,
and you're creating these
things that are just making it
look like the world is ending.
And I kind of get
that, at one level,
is that this is really apples
to oranges type of thing
because we're conflating PPM
values parts, per million
with meters, or space.
And they are two
different beasts,
and we're like
putting them together.
But I will say this.
As a scientist,
the first thing I
was trained as a freshman
was, if you have data,
and you're going
to graph it, use
the space available to
fit your data, you know,
and maximize that space.
So when I want to
plot this, I want
to make it visible
as best I can.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I think it might
be useful to come
up with a unit, that
is understandable as
a measurement unit.
It could be anything.
And I will not
mention that word,
but stuff that
comes out of us as--
I say, you know,
what is the concept?
So something that says--
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
Nathan's idea is
to sort of take just
sort of some number that
covers this whole
area for this leak,
so that it adds up the
whole area underneath that.
AUDIENCE: So you can bin that.
But what I'm saying, as
an understandable measure,
something that says the height
is measured in terms of a unit
that we all recognize as
a relevant unit for gas.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: But you could be able
to reverse model it, right?
So put it in an
atmospheric model
and say the concentration at
three feet above the ground
is X. What's the
leak rate have to be
to get that concentration
here in this pattern?
And figure out, how much
they're actually emitting,
and then you have a number
that is at least in terms
of their dollars, right?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: But it's
hard to do that somewhat
because the wind
will be going by.
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
Right, but the wind,
so you do it on a couple
of days, and you have,
you put in the wind
data to your model.
And then your model says, this
methane at this first rate,
it back-calculates--
from your concentration,
back-calculates an emission
based on the weather
data as well.
Normalize that over
multiple days of testing,
and then you say, this
roughly equates to X emission.
And there are
research groups that
are trying to do exactly that.
So what you have are the
turbulence experts, the people
that study micro meteorology,
and boundary layers,
and I'm not that person.
I know that person.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: I don't
even know dispersion.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: But these are
the future areas to take this
and to try to model.
AUDIENCE: See, I'm wondering
against whether this
is a physics problem or
a statistics problem.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yes.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yes, it is.
AUDIENCE: Because I feel
like some of these things,
you could get very
complex physics because
of the nature of the
scales at which you
were trying to model this
thing, or run a machine learning
algorithm against it and see
what is your best predictor.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: And
I just want to make
a really quick point
here is, like here's
one of these spikes, right?
This value, let's say
it's 10 PPM, that's
important on its own because,
for example, air quality is
related to concentration
of methane in the air.
It's a precursor to ozone.
The area under this
curve, we think,
may be a correlant for
how much is coming out.
And that becomes
an energy point,
or an equivalent carbon unit
is this area under the curve.
But you know, these
need to be validated.
Everyone in the
class now, I think,
I sent the email out,
you have the KML file.
You have this data.
You have an ASCII data
file, which generated this.
You'd have to-- the
columns are actually
pretty easy understand,
for the most part.
But you are now empowered.
This is community science.
And you can explore,
and analyze,
and run with this data.
AUDIENCE: I could forward it
to everybody who's signed in.
Nathan, I have an
unrelated question
that I'm really curious about.
Have you ever driven near
a cow farm, a beef farm?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: So the one
that sticks out in my mind is
driving from San Francisco to
LA on Interstate 5 getting close
to the Southern Mountains, giant
feed lot right next to I-5,
and very flat baseline,
and then, you know,
this very sloping increase
as we passed by that feed lot
to about, I think
it was 2 and 1/2,
3 parts per million of
methane going from below 2--
but the thing there,
it's not like this spike
like we're seeing here.
It's just this blob.
It's a very extended blob.
AUDIENCE: That's why I think
integration is important.
So you want to do not just a
spike but a spike times area.
AUDIENCE: Which an
air dispersion model
would essentially-- would do.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So we're
going to need somebody
to help us with this.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah,
these are great ideas.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to know, can you
get ahold of this device?
How much does it cost?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: The Picarro
analyzer that we used--
and that's now six, seven years
old, that was about $60,000.
And the manufacturer,
it's kind of like,
they don't have a price list.
They're like, call
us and let's talk.
AUDIENCE: So that's
just for the box
with the mirrors and the laser.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah, yeah.
So you know, it's not really--
AUDIENCE: This is the kind of
stuff we have to [INAUDIBLE]
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah.
But, what I will say
is that, or maybe
Audrey wants to talk
about the hand held?
The Sierra Club HEET thing.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah
HEET might, at some point
have a through Sierra
Club, Massachusetts
have a handheld device with
which you could check something
like that combustible gas
indicator for anybody who
is on the ride yesterday.
So you'd be able to
check the gas in the soil
to find out if a tree is being
poisoned by gas-- et cetera.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: And I can't
forget-- someone, who was it,
came up with the idea of
a bike, a bike trailer.
AUDIENCE: You did.
That was your idea.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Huh?
AUDIENCE: You were
talking about it.
That was your idea.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Oh.
Well--
[LAUGHTER] So that
would be amazing.
And there's a reason for it.
Because, as you mentioned,
you know these mains,
they can run, more
times than not,
they run kind of down
the middle of the street.
But they can go on sidewalks.
They can go on angles.
The service lines leak.
And so much of what
we've done has not
been looking at service lines,
the perpendicular, smaller
pipes that go into the houses.
So with a bike or a cart, or an
ability to get on sidewalks--
and to be able to move around
in Boston or Cambridge,
you know, if you ride a bike,
that's the most efficient way
to get around.
I mean, if there's a gridlock,
you're just going around.
So--
AUDIENCE: Baby carriages.
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
Or baby carriages.
And so Picarro does sell a
smaller unit than that one,
it's like a backpack unit.
But it could go in
a Burly trailer,
or it could go on your back
while you're riding a bike.
So I would love that.
It would be the first
one in the nation,
and I think it would be amazing.
So if we can crowdsource
that, generate some funds,
that would be great.
AUDIENCE: Well, couldn't
the existing Picarro
that you had in the van,
can that be mounted,
that and the battery
or power, could that
be mounted on our
trailer behind a bike?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah, it could.
We could actually make
a video with that,
and that would be like,
let's do it better--
because what you would use
there is, like a garden cart,
with those big
balloon knobby tires
to provide some
shock absorption.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
actually let me make
a point of some order,
which is now that we--
I think the formal portion
of your presentation
is done, right?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I think
that we can now
ask questions of all
the speakers, not just--
NATHAN PHILLIPS: After
giving Audrey a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
Can we have Susan's
last question?
AUDIENCE: I just was wondering
because, on the field trip,
I learned what the symbolism
is by the gas company,
and what kind of cast iron,
it was written on the sidewalk
here.
If the company has the
infrastructure in its archives,
is there enough
of a relationship
between the age of the pipe and
the material to know the leak,
so you could make big
assumptions about, OK,
if you know that, then you don
even have to do the monitoring.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: The Department
of Environmental Protection is
making that exact point,
in terms of basing all
of the state-wide greenhouse
gas methane emissions based
on exactly that calibration--
miles of cast iron,
miles of bare steel, et cetera,
and making an assumption that--
they know the exact rate of
emissions per mile of cast iron
main, and that they
don't even have
to check, either top down,
or bottom up, either.
And I think that's--
you could make a
guess at that, but you
have to check to
make sure it's right.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah, they
call the emissions factors
and activity factors.
And multiply A by B
and get a leak rate.
And these, I call them fudge
factors, they basically say,
cast iron has this many
leaks per linear mile.
That's your emissions factor.
Well, how many
miles do you have?
That's your activity
factor, multiply a by d,
there is your leak rate.
But those are
based on very old--
not just old data,
but very sparse data.
AUDIENCE: But can you calibrate
that with you leak data?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah,
that's we're doing.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: I
don't think it has much
to do with each other.
The Department of Environmental
Protection emissions factors
make it look like--
the problem is solved!
And I don't think
that that's true.
AUDIENCE: There are [INAUDIBLE]
emissions factors, right?
So they are from the industry,
and they're way outdated.
Like, this is true, they're
outdated for refineries,
so when they go out and do
modern testing on refineries
they see the tanks leak
at much higher rates
than their emissions
factors account for.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: So there's
a really interesting point
the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts
apparently has done an enormous
job at cleaning up our methane
leak problem because,
what they did was,
the DEP utilized an early set
of emissions factors natural gas
leakage from the mid
90s, and then one that
was much lower, from
2015 publication,
and they linearly interpolated
an emissions factor, so that--
they hardwired in a
reduction because two studies
showed two different
emissions factors
for the same kind of pipe.
So result you get, it appears
to make it look like we've
done really, really well.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Kind of
like, everything is solved.
And part of the way they
did they was, they got rid
of superemitters, or one of the
studies discarded any outliers.
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
Right, so the emissions
factors are based on leaks
are distributed like this.
But what we know is that leaks
are distributed like that.
They're long tail with a few--
AUDIENCE: I mean, I
would say that the normal
versus long tail is an error
across so many problems
and industries.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yes.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: And we can
all take a look at this data
and make a guess as to where
the long tail problem is.
It's fairly apparent.
AUDIENCE: So it's 50% from 7%?
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
That's what we--
Margaret Hendrick did a study--
that we did together--
that 7 of 100 leaks
accounted for 50%
of the gas loss.
AUDIENCE: If you take this
data as kind of the sample,
and multiply by the number
of rows and pipelines,
and you try to match
it with entire methane
inventory of the US, just
to see if the numbers are
the same orders of magnitude--
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah, we did.
Not with the entire US, but
we did it with Massachusetts
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
Yeah, so we found
that, if we took the chamber
measurements of leaks,
100 leaks, and we just
kind of multiplied that out
by the frequency of leaks
that we got previously--
that amount is consistent
with other estimates,
and are about one third
of the total methane
emissions estimated for the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts.
One third.
This collaboration, we have to
me, and with Mothers Out Front
as a kind of hybrid
advocacy science
nonprofit kind of
coalition, I've
never been involved
in anything like that,
and it's just been the most
fulfilling kind of partnership
for research science and policy.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.